[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
Les riches amis artistes se suffisent très bien
confier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Soit
[Musique]
Oui oui
Oui
[Musique]
et si
si nous ne le faisions pas
Je suis un partenaire courage
[Applaudissements]
avec sa queue
[Musique]
puis avec la tradition
il est congelé
[Musique]
me donne beaucoup de gens qui sont dans le
rue allons à ta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui
si le temps vivait
pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
Oui oui
[Musique]
tout seul
moi avec le regard
[Applaudissements]
avec johnson johnson johnson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je l'apprécie c'est
de famille
Cela prouve
oh
[Applaudissements]
mais non
Donc c'était ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]